is it true that you went to adam's
wedding and you were you married the two
of them um that is true is that pressure
for you or yes it is because who the i
mean what the [ __ ] i mean it's probably
tons of celebrities you know exactly
what i'm talking about yeah the last
thing i want to do
i want to enjoy his wedding also i'm
like you know and then i'm thinking like
then you become you know
you're like i'm writing all these things
and i realize i have no jokes right the
whole thing because i'm just trying to
be thoughtful and and respectful and
loving to these people who asked me to
do this main honor and then you the
[ __ ] sick egomaniac inside he goes
well i gotta kill a little bit too you
know and then like and then adam's like
yeah you should be funny like before you
know it i'm like jonah but now there's
even but now there's even more pressure
because now you got to be a little bit
witty and you got to do all of this yeah
and then
it does ruin the wedding for you i wrote
like one or two one joke i think or two
jokes and that i knew would work and
then i was just trying to be like did
you bring in other people to write for
you or did you do the whole thing
yourself are you bringing a team
how much do you how much do you charge
him for this uh a wedding uh 275 000
euros but it does ruin the wedding for
you doesn't it because no it would i
still had an amazing time but afterwards
like i finished the thing i'm [ __ ]
like
drained yeah
you know i left the party after like 30
minutes was it a jewish ceremony well no
because her dad is a south african
preacher which was also very funny
because
he's like yeah yo like at some point
his dad's got to come up and do some
like actual religious stuff or whatever
and i'm like
what and i'm like yeah great like why
doesn't he just do this you know
and he comes up and he kills it and then
he just
kind of goes to sit back down he like
looks back at me like that's how it's
done
[ __ ] you yeah maybe i'm not in the
movies but i know how to make a wedding
show money no yeah do you have trouble
picking what the vows are you're going
to lock them into or you know when
someone gets married and you're all
hanging out before the the groomsmen and
stuff hang out beforehand
and they're all like having fun and like
whatever you're nervous and i'm like
going over my [ __ ] in my head like what
i'm gonna say did you really uh leave
like a half hour after the ceremony was
over because you were so drained yeah i
left very early on oh [ __ ] i do remember
i think my joke the joke i wrote was
because like you know adam and i grew up
together or something and
um you know it's so nice to see all the
people we grew up like skateboarding
with growing up here like like
like jean
and um stevie nicks and robert downey jr
um
i was kind of like giving him [ __ ]
because i like really famous people at
his wedding